j'ai eu la sensation d'un seul coup tout
ce qu'on m'avait donné on l'a repris
d'un coup net
ça a été vraiment cette sensation et je
me suis retrouvé du coup
bah je me suis retrouvé comme le petit
garçon dans la cour d'école toi que tout
le monde regardait et donc si tu veux je
portais
si tu le sens la sensation d'abandon et
la sensation de honte
tu vois alors je sais plus la honte
d'être le de la cour de récréation
mais c'était la honte d'être le mec qui
vend plus de disques toi le looser en
fait
la première semaine de vente elle est un
peu fatidique et c'est vrai que c'est
super violent quand tu as une semaine de
vente on vous dit bon bah l'album est
plié il atteint pas les chiffres donc
c'est mort ce que ça réveille à ce
moment là chez moi c'est des failles
beaucoup plus anciennes qui débarquent
et je me prends en pleine tête à ce
moment-là et je me rends compte que je
suis hyper fragile et qu'en gros depuis
la nouvelle star donc depuis 2005 le
casting et 2006 la victoire qu'en gros
tout repose sur quelque chose de d'hyper
bancal et que je suis
ultra dépendant du regard des gens du
succès pour moi me sentir un minimum
solide or à ce moment là je me sens
hyper fragile pas du tout stable et
c'est là que ça commence un peu à bien
vriller quand même ce qui est très
violent c'est que quand on est artiste
c'est très difficile de dissocier ce
qu'on fait de ce qu'on est
souvent ça c'est con comme exemple mais
bon tu vas dans une boulangerie tu te
prends de baguette qui est un peu
grillée tu vas pas dire ah et
complètement faux c'est de boulangère
surtout la plus jamais tu dis bon dans
un malentendu avec quelqu'un qui te
téléphone à ce moment-là la foire et la
baguette mais c'est pas dramatique c'est
vrai quand tu as la sensation d'un rejet
parce qu'il y a pas une adhésion en fait
c'était ça le truc tu as la sensation
qu'en gros c'est parce que tu fais qui
est rejeté mais une finesse c'est ce que
toi tu es ce que tu représentes qui est
complètement ouais qui rejeté c'est
vraiment cette sensation là donc
dissocier ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on est
quand on est artiste c'est quand même
très compliqué et en même temps c'est
fondamental si tu veux et fondamental
dans les deux sens en cas d'échec et en
cas de succès et là je me dis en fait il
y a deux options c'est-à-dire que la
première option soit tu es
fondamentalement
sadomaso et tu aimes vraiment
t'exposer et de sentir tu vois fragile
comme ça et si tu veux clairement je me
dis c'est pas possible en fait c'est pas
c'est pas viable donc soit il y a cette
option là
soit il y a l'option non mais un moment
il va falloir travailler sur toi parce
que c'est pas possible en fait c'est pas
possible je me sentais pas du tout
solide pas du tout solide à l'idée
éventuelle de faire un autre album qui
ne marche pas tu vois donc si tu veux il
y avait ce truc là et c'est entraîné
tout un tas de questionnement avant que
je vois une psy tout un tas de
questionnements sur mes pourquoi je
faisais ce métier qu'est-ce que j'avais
besoin de combler et ce que je faisais
ce métier par ego tu vois est-ce que
c'était mon égo que je cherche à nourrir
est-ce que chercher à communiquer des
émotions avec les gens enfin tu vois
toutes ces questions là elles avaient
besoin d'être creusées
profondément et c'est ce que j'ai fait
en fait dès que la tournée s'est arrêtée
donc ça a été intense mais nécessaire
[Musique]
j'arrive à table
c'est mes parents et je venais de
réécouter l'album Rio et en fait quand
j'ai réécouté l'album j'étais en larme
parce que je disais mais moi en fait cet
album j'aime bien donc
même si la pas marché ben j'arrive on
arrivera pas à me faire dire que l'album
était pas bon il me correspondait au
moment où que je vivais moi dans ma vie
à ce moment-là en fait tu vois et donc
je suis arrivé à table
et d'un seul coup mes parents disent
alors qu'est-ce que tu faisais
tomber en larmes mais alors vraiment
violemment en disant mais je vais faire
un autre métier je comprends pas
pourquoi pourquoi on me dit que cet
album est a été pourri et mes parents
tuaient se sont retrouvés désemparés
parce que je suis jamais tombé en
sanglot comme ça devant eux mais même
justement quand j'ai subi du harcèlement
et tout ils m'ont jamais vu comme ça et
bizarrement le fait d'avoir tu vas
lâcher ça
ça m'a permis d'évacuer tu vois le poids
que j'avais sur moi et du coup petit à
petit j'ai gros commencé à me mettre
travail sur l'album panorama du coup et
je me suis dit bon ben à un moment
ce sera un peu tête de baisse Fab de
race tu vois et ma logique ça a été bon
bah à partir de maintenant stop quoi
c'est à dire que je vais faire un album
d'accord moi il me parlera à 100% peu
importe que on dit c'est bien c'est pas
bien moi j'assumerai je porterai un
album là où j'ai envie d'aller
d'une thérapie une thérapie et la psy
c'est la même que double jeu exactement
alors ça c'était vraiment une envie pour
moi réellement la thérapie de pS Je
t'aime cette fin de thérapie où je dis
bon bah je crois que j'ai fait le tour
maintenant passer à autre chose dans ma
vie réelle j'étais en train de terminer
la thérapie qui a eu lieu pendant toute
cette période là et pour moi c'était
symboliquement de dire bon ben voilà il
y a eu la théorie bon bah maintenant il
faut vivre l'expérience pas anorama
c'est une ode à la résilience et la
logique de se dire que rien n'est
permanent ni ce qui est positif ni
négatif et qu'il faut accepter ce qui
est au moment ça existe et les évacuer
pour avancer et aller vers autre chose
et donc j'espère cet album moi ça a été
exutoire cet album il est vraiment
arrivé à la fin de cette remise en
question qui a duré presque 5 ans donc
ça aide c'est vraiment un exutoire pour
moi j'espère qu'en tout cas il aura une
utilité pour ceux qui l'écouteront
pourquoi tu changes
je t'aime c'est quoi un problème ce que
je disais pourquoi c'est pas
[Musique]